you ever go into a new home and you turn
on the faucet
and there's no water comes out they have
restrictions and you know we're talking
about places you don't have a water
problem a lot of say most states don't
have a water problem in fact you do have
a water problem you have too much water
you don't know what to do with it so
they have restrictors so you're sitting
there washing your hands and it'll come
on water come out baby i want to wash i
have to tell you
if this guy hadn't been president of the
united states like in a normal country
where this guy wouldn't be elected
this would actually be hilarious like
this is hilarious but they made this guy
president i got rid of it same thing
with showers i'd go into a shower
and i'd go to a hotel that was new and i
said i can't stay in these places why
the water just drips out a little bit
slowly i want to take good care of my
hair
i don't want that no it's true
i mean i put the soap in it takes you 20
minutes to have the water come out to
get the damn soap out of your hair